so let's start right back at the
beginning
when the dinosaurs roamed the Earth well
not literally but just
metaphorically at least so
a little brief pre-history of C plus
plus the historical context that it was
born into
again a lot of this will be familiar but
maybe some of the details
though you may not have known but we can
trace it all back to 1957
the our goal language was really the the
first language that so the looks
somewhat familiar as a modern
programming language there were other
languages before which are much more
specialized about and our goal was
really this first sort of General
programming language that had a lot of
the same sort of features that we still
have today
1962 we have a simula you see it's off
to the side there because it follows a
slightly different lineage but actually
similar the original simulator was a
strict superset of algol
in fact originally it was just a front
end for for alcohol then later it sort
of branched off into its own
um it's on Fork but yeah it's a just the
object-oriented
um features on top of algol uh strictly
speaking
but on the non-o side we continue the
lineage down 1963 CPL
1967 B CPL and these are all
um you know pretty much one inheriting
from the other
69b until finally 1972 we got the C
language
now Cross C is still around and popular
today we don't tend to see much of CPL
bcpl or B
so why why don't we even put them in
here why are they important
well
sometime in the 70s
a certain Beyond a strong strap was
doing his PhD thesis
and he was using two languages bcpl
and similar for two different things
and what he found was that
simula had all the high level
abstractions that he really wanted
real actor as a language but
it didn't perform very well it wasn't
really a systems language even though it
had its roots in alcohol
whereas bcpl was much closer to the
metal
I didn't have any any problems with that
but it's just much harder to work with a
bit too low level so you really wanted
something that had the best of both
worlds
and that really was the the initial
motivation for coming up with a new
language that combined the strengths of
those two branches
big CPL and similar in his case and it's
a little bit later
that he then came up with that language
originally called C with classes
now rebased on C rather than bcpl
and again taking the oo stuff from
simula
but what I wanted to emphasize here is
that that aspect of
no compromise
we want the low level access and the
high level of abstractions without
trading anything off that was that's
what he was aiming for
and of course in the 80s finally got a
name proper name C plus plus
at the window today but 1985 was when it
first came known as C plus plus but
really it started in 1979.
so who here was using in 1979
so let's go back to what we were just
saying what we're talking about zero
cost abstractions that's really what
that Insight that uh that Guyana had
back then combining those two languages
and closely related to that or sometimes
sort of an application of it
or a secondary effect don't pay for what
you don't use
so it's okay to have other abstractions
that do have a cost but you should only
pay for them if you use them those two
things really go nicely together
you can see now how that was right at
the heart of C plus plus or even before
that right from the very beginning
so
that's the pre-history
let's now just move a little bit further
forward in time to the first Standard
Version
of C plus plus so it wasn't standardized
until 1998 very first C plus plus
standard
and as we'll mention of it in a minute
we sometimes today talk about C plus
plus 98 03 is if it's a single language
mostly because O3 didn't really add much
in the way of where anything really in
the way of features you can think of it
more as a bug fix release
so these days
we're really talking about C plus plus
O3 but started with 98.
there was a lot different in C plus plus
98 to the original
C with classes that then became C plus
plus through the 80s
but before we get to that let's go back
a little bit
talk about some of the things that C
plus plus as a language
introduced to the systems programming
world
classes of course may be the first thing
that comes to mind it was right in the
original names seaweed classes
as a way of doing object-oriented
diffractions
that but obviously borrowed from simula
with a few changes but actually if you
look back at simula
a lot of the syntax is very very similar
you can see it directly borrowed across
along with that but some separate
features inheritance
you don't have to be able to do
inheritance to use classes but
back in the day they sort of went hand
in hand
again closely related polymorphism
so being able to treat different
instances as if they have a common
subset
one way or another an encapsulation they
have to hide access or restrict access
to certain parts of your classes so that
well there's various reasons you do that
this is not a talk about that
just wanted to sketch in the flavor of
the most important features the original
version of C plus
but then there was more that
particularly came in through the 90s
templates maybe the big one
but even inline functions
which is one thing that really separated
it from C
the relying Less on the preprocessor to
do things
and overloaded functions things that we
take for granted now
all introduced in maybe the late 80s
early 90s
now really bringing C plus plus 98 into
it the big thing that came in C plus
plus 98 was the STL the standard
template Library obviously relied on
templates being fully formed at that
point again we take it for granted now
it's such an idiomatic part of the
language that we forget it only really
came about in 1998
so those of you that had your hand up to
say you're using C plus plus before 98
remember what it was like and what that
transition was like it's like this is a
new language
it really was transformative change the
way you thought about things
uh well dig into yesterday a little bit
more as we go through
but I want to mention one other thing
which often gets lost to the mix here
which I think is really pivotal to a lot
of the complexity of C plus plus
is its use of what we call references
now when I Was preparing this material
for a largely non-c plus audience I took
a little bit more time to explain what
we mean by references because it's a bit
different to what most other people
I mean when we talk about reference
semantics
we're talking in general about things
that refer to other things
um in C plus plus we have two ways to do
that and one of which we call references
so it gets a bit confusing when you're
talking across cross language but
again this is really basic and
fundamental but I want to step through
this
let's show you where I'm going with it
so in C plus plus of course we we have
value types
Primitives like integers of course you
can create your own types but
why we call them value types the value
is really that 42 there in this case
whereas I
we can think of it as a name for Value
but in practice it's what we call an
object
you don't have to have a class to have
an object an object is just a location
in memory that has a certain meaning
so even that integer
it's somewhere in memory
and that means that you can get
for example a pointer to it so now we
have a pointer to that particular
integer
so if we now change I to a different
value P points to the new value and the
way around
we know this
and of course we can also take a
reference to that integer
most lipids are the same properties that
I just described so why do we have two
mechanisms in the language that do sort
of the same thing
of course partly that's historical
C already had pointers
we wanted to do better
quite late in the day really Biana
introduced references
so some we often say that this pointer
in a class it should really have been a
reference but when he invented to this
point we didn't have references yet
it actually came later than we think
what's the advantage of references
we put it in a table you can see the
differences
so
both pointers and references where you
can initialize them to the value of
course we just saw that
they're assignable in the sense that if
you
assign a value to them
right through to the original variable
whereas any pointers are rebindable
and point them to a different
object a different memory address
pointers also have a different syntax
you have to either de-reference or use
the arrow
syntax whereas references they look just
like other values
pointers are actually just an address
it's what they point to
they were interested in
but we can actually get the address
itself
there is an address behind references
but it's hidden
and only pointers are nullable so if you
don't want to point to anything at all
you can point them at null
now what's interesting is that all of
those things that look like an advantage
for pointers that's mostly where the
problems are
usually where we get into trouble
so really
if we can get away with just the first
two we should always be using references
only reach for pointers if you need the
other things
again this basic stuff but sometimes
it's worth reminding ourselves of those
Basics and
where they're really coming from
so
we can also
um
introduce the const keyword
and cons can be applied
at different levels so this uh the
second line here constant star
it's a pointer to
a constant in
but we can also apply the const to the
pointer so it's a constant pointer to a
non-constant and if we combine the
cartoons we've got a constant pointer to
a constant in
now
I know some of you are thinking why why
you put in the constant on the left hand
side
so who here identifies themselves as
these const
ant not many there's a few a few people
finally admitting it
um I've got a slide for you in a moment
but it does look a bit confusing and
even as experienced two plus plus
developers as most of us are
it can be hard to follow this sometimes
but this is what we've got with with
pointers
now
in fact I've put the extra slide in here
so
the top level cons the one that applies
to the value itself or the value type
like the first one constant that const
can go before or after the type so we
can also do that so this is
this is what we mean by is const so
when it's to the right or to the East
and the type it applies to you've got to
catch your name a couple of years ago
why would you do that it seems to be
non-idematic
well actually if you look can you see
that we've got this sort of
inconsistency like zigzagging where the
end is if you go down but
we put the in first
it's always in the same place
well that's the first thing but more
importantly now take the bottom one for
example we can read it right to left
it's a const pointer to a constant
doesn't really work this way around
now this is not a talk about iscon so
I'm not going to go any further I will
say
that I do have some ACE cons wristbands
if you want them
come and get them afterwards all right
really this is just to just to remind us
how complex this stuff really gets just
dealing with with pointers now
references this is the story
the replace the reference itself is
implicitly constant you can't rebind so
you can't change it to reference to
something else so you don't have to
worry about that case
we've got a meetable reference and a
conch reference and that's it
obviously you can have references to
pointers and so on but
then we're bringing pointers back in
and that's really at the heart of it
the the restrictions if you like on
references
actually open up Simplicity and certain
guarantees
you know while you can have a reference
ending up pointing to something that's
null that shouldn't happen that's a bug
so you'd never have to do null checks
you don't have to worry about things
changing
there's lots of guarantees you get from
using references
so that that's really what these missing
parts actually give us
and just to put that in pictures
well if you've got a value you could
have appointed to it we can have a
reference to it
might be the pointer or the reference
could become
sorry the pointer of the value can be
constant
reference is always const
there were emission values
you can deal with just values without
worrying about pointers or references
and there's certain advantages to doing
that
mostly you don't have to worry about all
the complexity of what we just talked
about
and we tend to call that way of
approaching things value semantics
or value oriented programming
and C plus plus gives us a number of
ways to make this easier
in particular
unlike many other languages There's no
distinction in the type
between what say a value type or
something that's meant to be used with
reference semantics
like for example in C sharp a class is
always a reference type and the
structure is always a value type
no anything could be a value type or a
reference type
but C plus plus gives you a number of
other things on top of that that make
working with value types even more
powerful and perhaps the most powerful
of all
is what we call raii which is a bit
unfortunate
that we call it that but it's stuck
and just as a reminder
it stands for resource acquisition is
initialization
but really it's it's just about
destructors
and again just to put that in an example
not going to labor it too much because I
know we're familiar this but
um you'll have a Constructor and a
Destructor and they are very strictly
scoped so
if we have some code like this then
the destructor for sr2 here will get
called exactly at the point that we hit
the closing Kodi brace
again fundamental stuff if we're in
experienced C plus plus programmer
so much so that we forget that most
other languages don't have this
deterministic destruction is almost
completely unique to C plus plus I think
there's one or two other less mainstream
languages that may have it
and some other languages have other
features that try to approximate it
but they don't quite get all the way
the guarantees this gives you when
you're managing other resources are
things that we take for granted and
other
languages have to have workarounds to
achieve
oh just to
illustrate this again I won't
dwell on it too much
because I think we're familiar with it
but we can
precisely predict when those things are
going to happen and that's fairly unique
okay
as a consequence of that
we have these higher level types that we
can build in the libraries like like
vector
managing a dynamic array in C
is where we get the
um
this sort of image of it will bring
about manual memory management and that
being very tricky to manage we don't
generally worry about that in C plus
plus because we have types like vector
that will manage and memory for us
of course we can write our own memory
managing
memory managing types
but let's have a look at Vector and
let's just work for a little example
so Vector is a dynamic arrange we said
we can declare one like this it's going
to be empty
how do we get stuck in it of course we
know we can we can push back a value
if we want to push a load of values on
well we've got to do load of pushbacks
in C plus plus 98 remember that's where
we are at the moment
pretty much the only way to do it
there's there's one Constructor where
you can just put a load of the same
value at once
but other than that you're pushing back
or using something on top of that
and that gets a bit tedious
the other thing is
when we create the vector there it's got
us maybe a small pool of memory in it
and at some point probably on the
pushback two maybe even the first the
second one
that's not going to be enough so it has
to allocate some more use your doubles
each time so here you're probably got
about three memory allocations
so of course you know you can reserve
something up front if you know how how
big it's going to be
and you know we we told ourselves well
this is the cost of
um that low level access
and now we've got very fine control over
when memory allocations happen and so on
but it's tedious
introduce another Vector this time of
strings
and what we want to do
is convert all of the integers into
Strings and store them in the second
vector
should be straightforward
first thing we need to do well first of
all after declaring the vector we know
what the size is now so we can we can
reserve that
we've got a
um
iterate over
all of the elements in the original
vector
C plus plus 98 so
we'll be using iterators
begin and end
now we're still using arthritis of
course
starting to change in C plus plus 20
we'll get on to that later but
yeah we're familiar with how these work
but before C plus plus 98 this was a
pretty alien concept
would be indexing or maybe using
pointers and actually it's a rate of the
modeled after pointers
but iterate has really changed the game
now what when we talk about generic
programming
we often think of templates
we've got the standard template Library
all of the containers are templated
that's an archetypes after all but
actually
when we talk about C plus plus being a
generic programming language
we mostly talk about iterators
because they abstracted not just the
types but the shape of the containers as
well
with iterators
we can be agnostic most of the time to
what type of container we're using as
long as it implements the authorator
interface we can write algorithms
completely separately
so to those and they will mostly just
work obviously there's some differences
iterator categories we're not going to
get into that too much
so yes it's hard to overstate how much
of a game changer iterators were when
they came out in C plus 98
but again using the
them to be a bit tedious so
we probably need to store them in some
intermediate variables
now let's capture the begin and end into
two iterators
if we're not going to be changing what
the iterator points to we probably need
a const iterator
again it's modeling a pointer but we
can't actually put that in the syntax
that it's a constant iterator so we have
to spell it out
that means we've got these really long
type names
no type inference in C plus plus 98 so I
had to spell it out all the time
and then we can actually do our Loop
now of course you can write those
in the the head of the loop but because
it's over bugs
usually we had to separate it out just
so we could read it unless you're really
careful with the formatting
so yeah very often we'd write it like
this
okay so we're iterating over our
integers
now we want to convert the integers into
Strings
well one way to do it which was somewhat
idiomatic if not particularly efficient
it's just use a string string
I won't go into this too much I'm sure
you're familiar with string strings but
yeah we can we can stream that integer
in and then we can do dotstra when it to
get the string out straightforward stuff
as I say there's quite a setup cost in
constructing it so there's there were
various workarounds if you really cared
about the performance of this but
this was readily understood
we'll go with it
so okay we've got all of our integers
converted to Strings and put into our
second Vector great
now just to show you that we can still
use indexes
will iterate over that
using an integer index
and this is the output we get as
expected obviously you can't really tell
that they're strings at this point but
we know that they are
okay there's all the code that we've
ended up with a lot of code for such a
simple task just for fun
I thought I'd do the same thing in
Python
the code for the complete example in
Python is less than the code for our
final Loop in C plus plus 98.
so yeah again we we told ourselves well
this is just the cost of
being able to be low level but remember
's original motivation was yeah he
wanted the high level of abstractions as
well he wanted to have his cake and eat
it
but we weren't quite there yet
for this background
so okay
um
we'll switch gears a little bit I'm
going to come back to this
but I want to talk for a moment about
classes
so we said that you know classes have
been around since the early days of C
plus plus uh again we're all familiar
with this I'm sure but
this is this is the class that has two
members
a string
as a name and then a vector that we're
going to call data
that's weird structure in order to get
the values in
so we can construct it in one hit which
meant repeating we've got a string and a
vector and then repeating the links
again
to to copy them in
and there's lots of copies involved even
if we're using the contrast
and then maybe we want to add some
accesses
um
and yeah there's a lot of code here
again to achieve very little but that's
that's what we had
and still like she had today
okay let's use this so
we're going to need some data to put in
so we'll create a vector we have to use
pushback
let's get some data in
and now we'll construct one of those
classes
passing the string of the data okay so
far so good so this is now a value type
if this is in a function it's going to
be a local variable on the stack
it could be part of another class of
course
okay
now if we want to call one of those
accesses say that the name member we can
do that with the dot syntax we're
familiar with
great all right
but
very often we create classes because we
want to use reference semantics and to
do that we need to allocate the incident
on the Heap
so we can use the new keyword which will
allocate on the Heap and invoke The
Constructor
and then we get a pointer
and as we said pointers have different
syntax so we have to use the arrow to
get to name instead of the DOT
at least this was pre-standard C plus
plus way of doing it
and that means now we've got this object
on the Heap we have to do a manual
memory management so we're gonna have to
delete it simply and that's a bit that's
easy to forget
so say plus plus 98
introduced Auto pointer
now there have been smart pointers
around before
C plus plus is auto pointer
but this was the first smart pointer in
the standard
and
the first look is seemed to solve the
problem now we can
create on the Heap start in the auto
pointer
we've got the same syntax to get to name
but
now I don't have to delete it because
that's happening in the district with
the auto pointer so we've effectively
applied some of the value semantics too
to a pointer
okay
but then things get weird
if we want to
assign that
Auto pointer to another Auto pointer
well what happens who owns the the
memory now
well even if you went around
back in the day you probably know how
Auto pointer works it actually
destructively mutates
um the thing it's designing from so
after this line object there
will be
not pointing anything anymore
it's transferred the ownership towards
two
which was a really nice thing to be able
to do
very valuable
this is a unique ownership property and
very often what we want but also a bit
surprising
and didn't really follow the the C plus
plus semantics property to the point
that
you couldn't actually use them in the
standard containers because they were
just lose what they were pointing to
just wasn't set up to handle that
so if you try to put one of these into a
stud Vector for example it wouldn't even
compile they had to put some tricks in
to stop it compiling because it's so
dangerous
so we managed to put a feature into the
standard Library
that were so dangerous we couldn't use
it with other parts of the standard
Library
think about that for a moment
but the idea was good
so we'll come back to that
so there's plenty more we can say about
C plus 98 we're trying to sketch out
some of the things we have to deal with
jog our memories a bit if we haven't
coded that way for a while or at all
Maybe
um
you see it's slightly moving I mentioned
C plus plus O3 that came and went
actually
going back to vector
who remembers
what changed about stood Vector in C
plus plus O3
Harold
the standards required
yeah so
before C plus plus O3 in the original C
plus plus 98 Vector was not required to
be contiguous in memory or the the
buffer that it pointed to
all the compilers all the mainstream
ones at least implemented it that way it
turned out to be really useful to rely
on it that way of course
so O3 fix that that was one of the
biggest changes in O3 there's a few
others but
this may be the most impactful one
is that actually
[Music]
moved maybe I didn't start my animation
okay now it's moving right
so 98 was around for a while O3 uh
Coleman went and there was a lot of talk
about
the next upcoming standard what was
going to be there it's going to be a big
release
and we talked about C plus plus no X
because we didn't know what year it was
going to be coming in just there's going
to be some time in the next few years
so C plus plus o x
um new smart pointers all sorts of
things but maybe one of one of the
biggest features that were promised
we're really looking forward to
was Concepts
and we kept hearing about how great this
was going to be
and so we didn't mind that it kept
delaying and delaying actually we did
mind but
what could we do
um and actually
we started to get to the end of the
2000s and we just still didn't have C
plus plus Ox so for a while
we joked actually it was hex and we had
another six years yet but then just for
a brief time we started talking about C
plus plus 1X
when we started together
a bit real
um but it's only a brief time because
then suddenly say plus 11 was here
and say plus plus 11 well okay it didn't
have Concepts
one of the reasons that
um the pre this standard delayed so long
was because
concept wasn't really ready
and eventually we realized we couldn't
fix it in time we had to take it out
unfortunately
a lot of the standard Library had now
come to be re-specified in terms of
Concepts and that all had to be undone
as well so just taking it out took time
so we eventually got C plus plus 11
without Concepts
a little bit disappointing
but also turned out to have a lot of big
new features
but at this point yeah 13 years
had elaps and C plus plus 98 so if we
ignore O3 didn't really add any new
features
people have got used to C plus plus just
being the same
and it was getting a bit old other
languages had
surpassed it in many ways
was it even relevant anymore
is it too late
was it enough to change things
well
this was the point that I was gonna
say we should take a break but I got
here faster than I expected because I
skipped some bits so maybe we'll uh
we'll tackle this question before the
break instead
so a few things happened
in the meantime
so first of all
Moore's Law
basically started to dry up at least
four single core
um well single cross
so up until that point Moore's law was
predicting that the number of
transistors on a chip would double every
two or three years to get the exact
frequency but we're pretty
strictly on that curve for for decades
really
18 months okay thank you
but sometime in the mid
early 2000s
I started to slow down actually quite
quite sharply
and before that point but particularly
through the 90s
if you were developing in the 90s
especially in C plus plus
you're probably used to hearing a lot
that we shouldn't worry too much about
performance because next year the
process will be fought twice as fast
so yes spend your time on developer
productivity and that's why languages
like Java and C sharp
really became popular because I mean
they're actually quite performant
themselves these days but back then
there was a big performance across to
use those languages but it didn't matter
because processors were getting faster
at a bigger rate
but with Moore's Law slowing down there
was a refocusing back on low level
performance sudden it became a bit more
important again because our Ambitions
were still growing
The Simpsons were building were still
bigger
and we needed to be more productive
so seemed to be a bit of an impossible
Matrix really
but
yeah there was a refocusing on
performance but also
we realized that actually we needed to
be able to more easily make our code
more parallel
so we could take advantage of multiple
calls because that seemed to be the next
step and as we've seen how it's played
out that's mostly been the case
maybe not quite as much as we thought
but
that was another problem for C plus plus
98 it didn't actually have a Threading
model
at all
uh doing multi-freading and C plus was
possible using third-party libraries but
it was basically undefined Behavior it
just worked in most cases but not part
of the standard at all C plus plus 11
we've got a
um a Threading memory model and some
basic Primitives
we still needed some high level stuff to
really take advantage of
parallel processing and we'll see later
how we're actually still working towards
that but that was the start of it
so yeah we've got the basics of
threading
refocusing on
low-level performance
and then the big thing was all these
languages that are surpassed yet had all
these nice new modern features and C
plus plus was a bit left behind in that
syntax we just looked at
but it got a load of features that
cleaned up enough of that not all of it
but enough of it that it actually made
working with it much more productive
so
was around around this time that herb
Sutter wrote an article some of you may
remember the free lunch is over
talking about
Moore's Law finishing and the need to
move to parallel and why C plus bus
should be a big part of that
um turned out that you know that really
was
sort of capturing the mood at the time
and
a pivotal point that took a few years
I'd say maybe even into the C plus 14
era
but
now I need to be get renewed interest
and people coming back to sleep last bus
but a whole new generation
the C plus plus Developers who rather
than being attracted to other languages
came straight to C plus plus
and so I would say that we avoided our
old mobile moment we did actually manage
to appeal to a new generation
we pulled it off
and now
we're moving on from that
so
let's have a look
at some C plus plus 11 stuff
so
we looked at this example earlier in the
context of C plus 98
remember we're just fitting a vector
with integers
and then converting those to Strings and
stuffing them in another another vector
a load of code we looked at the python
comparison all right let's take this a
bit at a time all those pushbacks we had
to do and even the reserve very tedious
and of course C plus 11 gave us
initializer lists but we did that in one
line pretty much just like in Python
slightly different syntax
okay great stop now what about this bit
this was a really messy bit
first of all we
we found those iterators really tedious
to work with iterators are great in
concept
but there's such a pain to use in
practice so of course we've got type
reduction cleaned up a load of that we
can use Auto now
because we don't really need to worry
about that type it's not really giving
us much information
for the iterator
now somebody who took this further
and who here identifies as almost always
Auto
no I think more than these concerts
actually yeah I'm one of them as well so
the idea is you use cons wherever you
can and mess that type would really
convey useful information
turns out to be maybe less than you
think
or maybe I just haven't looked at my old
code recently
but yeah that cleaned up a lot so that's
a good start
it's still basically the same
so
actually I would say that cleaned it up
enough we can now move the
iterator initialization into the
um the head of the for Loop so that's
good
what about our conversion to
string
well
then we have stood two strings which is
still not the most performant way to do
it if that matters to you you might
still roll your own
but just as a go-to this is so much
nicer than the the old string string way
so that's nice as well
but of course you're all thinking what
about
the range base for Loop we don't even
need to specify the iterators at all we
could just let the compiler do that for
us
we just want each integer in in the the
vector great
this is starting to look
a lot nicer
of course some of you are thinking no
that's that's not far enough
really we
we should use algorithms and of course
we could have done this in C plus plus
98 we had stood transform
we've got we're back with our iterators
this would have been the better way to
do it to start with but you notice I've
left a little bit here
unspecified
reason is
before C plus plus 11
we probably would have had to do
something like this
no okay we could have done it with a
function pointer as well but
bear with me
so
with these algorithms
that take something to be executed on
each iteration
we can supply it say a function pointer
or a function like object function
object
which is basically any class or struct
that has a call operator
so we'll write code like this
so that that's just calling on to just a
string
in fact we probably could just passed a
pointed just a string two two string
um no
no
um
address yes so you're right shouldn't
take an address of a standard function
because
the the signature is not stable or it
may be overloads I've kind of stuck with
that
good point so we would need to wrap it
anyway
but yeah this was we did this a lot back
in C plus plus 98
we forget sometimes
of course in C plus plus 11. we've got
lambdas now we can write the same thing
in line
and when I say the same thing
I'm not just saying that to to brush it
to one side
bat Lambda is actually isomorphic to
the function object
to the point that that's even how it's
specified in the standard that it is
isomorphic which is a really useful way
of thinking about it if you're not quite
sure about lifetimes or where things are
stored just think well if I unrolled
this as a as a functional object what
would it look like
and for just a
simple Lambda with no captures
it really is just a wrapper around a
function
but
of course we can
capture
variables at a Lambda if we put in the
square brackets of course
and that is really like a call to a
Constructor on a functional object so
we'll then store it in a member that you
have access to
in the body of the Lambda
and again that's exactly how it's
specified
so it can be useful to think of it that
way
and of course a lot of the complexity of
working with lambdas again comes back to
references in the language
we have to distinguish between things
that we're capturing by value or by
reference or in some case
values that are Pointers
the biggest one of course being
capturing the this pointer accidentally
the bane of working with lambdas
but
the point is again we have very fine
control
and as long as you point some of those
pitfalls it's a much nicer way of
working
so
lambdas would one of the biggest
features of C plus 11.
um oh there's an example of
capturing by reference
and by the way of course I've specified
what I'm capturing here
um whether it's by value or by reference
we can capture everything
by value by reference with a shorthand
syntax
but that's what puts you in danger of or
capturing things you hadn't intended to
especially that this pointer
because if you think you're capturing a
member variable
and it works it's because you're
capturing the this pointer and you may
have a lifetime issue there so
something to watch for
let's go back to this example
with the the auto pointer
the 9803 way of doing things
and of course C plus plus 11 that was
deprecated
no surprise given how dangerous it was
as we said
and of course it was replaced by
unique pointer
now
what made it possible to replace it with
an egg pointer
is move semantics our value references
which are not going to dig too deep into
again a big topic that I'm sure you're
mostly familiar with but
allowed you to specify an overload for
the thing that can move or transfer
ownership rather than taking a
destructive copy
so
unique pointer worked exactly as Auto
pointer with meant to have worked
if we had that facility to start with
so there's no reason to use Auto pointer
after that point in any new code at all
in fact it was removed from C plus plus
17. there's very few things that are
ever completely removed from C plus
I think I looked it up with like a
little page full
over the history of C plus plus
one of them is auto pointer again that
tells you a lot
about how dangerous it was
now that means that if we do try to just
use an assignment like this like we did
with auto pointer which would have
compiled that doesn't compile with
unique pointer
because
in fact it tells you at least my
compiler did cool to implicitly deleted
copy Constructor no copy Constructor on
unique pointer
instead
we have to use that move
what does stood move do
it does not move
stood move just basically converts what
you pass to it into an R value reference
that will then invoke the correct
overload
of the unique pointer in this case
Constructor
and that's what we'll do the transfer of
ownership
The Constructor on unique pointer
um
thought I'd have something else to say
on that but maybe not so I'm glossing
over a lot here I know it's a big topic
but I'm assuming most people are
familiar with it anyway more to show you
how we're moving forwards
oh yeah here we go
I did have something else so
this is what it looks like on the other
side
so if we're defining our own type with a
move Constructor in this case
well we usually have to
move the individual members as well
um
I'm not sure what that oh yeah and we
can use that move
for copy Constructors or sorry normal
Constructors as well and instead of
using confref
you see the contrast on the string and
the the vector
take those by value and then move them
in
that actually
means that you can
um
you can pass Temporaries in that
don't construct new types along the way
I think that's yeah all I'd say about
move semantics for now
so
this is some of the things we've looked
at
with C plus 11. plenty more
that we haven't covered we haven't
touched on variantic templates
perfect forwarding Contacts Pro
actually we'll say a little bit about
that
because again we're probably familiar
with contacts but maybe we forget how
limited it was in C plus plus 11. I had
to look it up myself
no variables no loops
and in practice no if statements I think
they were technically allowed
but there's nothing you could really do
with them without their variables or
multiple return statements so
really it's just single line Expressions
that always return the value
so very limited
but we didn't have them at all before so
it was a big step forward so yeah just
to sketch it in this allow you to to
write functions that could be executed
at comparting
didn't have to be
and we'll see how that progresses in
future versions as we get to that
so that's the big list already but
there's plenty more this is not
complete we mentioned the freight away
memory model already
but it was a huge release
so many of these things we use every day
today introduced in C plus plus 11.
that's wonderful things I meant to
highlight here but
I think we'll uh we'll move on
yeah
oh yeah that's right
you might have noticed shared points are
unique pointer in a different color
there
the reason is all the others
are actually language features
that's just language features
there's a load of new library features
as well
as well as the the smart pointers
again many of these are pretty big in
their own rate
um
some of them
maybe not so widely used today the regex
class the random number generator
they've got a few limitations
but the rest of them
are pretty fundamental
came in in C plus plus 11.
the other thing that came in with C plus
plus 11 was non-technical
was a reaction to What had happened
before
we knew that we'd really got into
trouble
between C plus plus 98 and 11. it just
took so long
but we've got to do something
differently so
we switched from
shipping a standard when we thought it
was ready
to shipping on a schedule
and we decided every few years
X years whatever new standard and after
a bit of discussion we thought we'd give
three years a try
so
the next one would be C plus plus 14.
2014 we did on schedule release C plus
plus 14. what was in it
well
that big gap between C plus plus 98 and
C plus plus 11
what we had to undo a load of mistakes
we made there was still a lot in it it
was a huge release C plus plus 14 was
always going to be a smaller release and
in fact in many ways be consider it more
a bug fix release not really not just
bugs but just refining what we already
had
sort of rounding it out a bit so things
like what make unique is maybe the prime
example really should have been the C
plus plus 11.
so
plus plus 11 introduced unique pointer
and shared pointer
now shared pointer also got make shed
one of the advantages of make shared
which will create the object afford your
Constructor arguments and then give you
back a shared pointer is that it reduces
the possibility of a leak if one of the
evaluations of your arguments froze an
exception
so exactly the same you should have
applied to Unique pointer but for some
reason this got overlooked we didn't
have a make unique
easy enough to write your own I know I
did who here wrote their own make unique
few hands yep
many of us did it it was fairly easy
once you had all the parts but much
nicer to have it in the language C plus
plus 14 gave us that
little thing but yeah so it's a nice
thing to have
a lot of it was like that just little
little refinements Another One Auto
lambdas
so we've got lambdas in C plus 11. big
feature on its own rack we've looked to
that but you always have to specify all
of the the types of the arguments
there's no templated lambdas of course
C plus plus 14 go for those so instead
of the template syntax
because we already now had Auto for type
deduction we use Auto for generic types
in the lambdas themselves much nicer why
didn't we have that for function
templates as well
later as we'll see we do but C plus plus
14 they came to to lambdas so yeah lots
of little rounding out and things
another one that I like auto return
types so you stick Auto at the start
actually we had Auto
at the start of a function definition in
C plus plus 11. but you still have to
specify the return type using the
trailing return type syntax with the
arrow I've done a whole talk and why I
actually prefer that anyway I'm not
going to cover that now but C plus plus
14 you didn't have to specify that type
if it could be deduced
little thing but yeah nice
there was more of course again lots of
little things they all add up to a nice
release but nothing really
earth-shattering
um
you know things like digit separators
it just makes long numbers a bit more
readable but okay
good
so I don't actually have a lot more to
say about C plus 14 other than
nobody particularly dislikes it but it's
just like a stepping stone onto the
bigger things so but
when I saw that talk on what's coming in
C plus 14 what's coming in C plus plus
17.
C plus plus 17 was always build as the
next big release
you know all the big things are going to
go into 17. and because of that
we put up with 14 just being a minor
increment
because we knew we were still waiting
for the big fingers including concepts
for example and actually by that time we
were expecting a few big things
so Concepts
maybe co-routines ranges modules
um
and there's another one I'm forgetting
but we'll come to it
so
let's skip on let's say plus plus 17.
see what we actually got
well it turns out we didn't get Concepts
we didn't get Co routines we didn't get
ranges we didn't get modules
uh contracts maybe it was the other one
none of those big features actually made
into 17 after all and so initially
it seemed like a big disappointment like
we put up with the small release C plus
plus 14 because we're waiting for this
one
and it didn't deliver except actually
when the dust settled and we had a look
at what we actually did get turned out
to be quite a good release at its own
rate yeah it didn't have those big
headline features but it had quite a lot
of really nice stuff so let's have a
look
in fact let's go back to our earlier
example remember we cleaned up
our vector so that yeah we didn't have
to do all those pushbacks we do all in
one line
it's a huge difference in C plus plus
11. now in 17 we went that just that
little bit further
see now
we didn't have to specify the template
type
we have something called ctad
which is Bob put it up class template
argument deduction without that since C
plus plus 17 but who who sort of
remembers that we even have this
yeah we forget it's maybe not a huge
feature but it's really nice actually
just sort of completes that don't
specify things you don't need to I feel
so even closer to python now
seated itself to do it right it's
actually a bit complex behind the scenes
but in use generally makes things a bit
simpler that's a common theme in all of
this
let's um
look at another example So based on what
we were looking at before we were
converting integers to Strings let's do
it the other way around
you've got a string
that you know may hold
a representation of an integer we want
to convert it to an INT again we can use
a string string trick we do have stood
from the string we're going to ignore
that for the moment
now bear in mind this is C plus plus 17.
what can we do better than this so we're
taking a stood string by cost reference
so
if you remember back from the C plus 98
days that's always been the best
practice
take potentially larger objects by cons
reference
potentially with move semantics we could
take it by value
and then move it I don't think that
really applies here cons reference seems
to be the right thing to do
but
if you pass this a say a child star
array string literal or maybe in some
some other string type that you've got
where you're going to pay a copy cost so
just to convert it to it you first got
to convert it to a different string
so of course we introduce string View
to solve that problem
string view itself is ridiculously
simple well look at the standard
implementation has some complexities to
it of course
but conceptually it's really simple who
here has written their own version of
something like string view before say
plus plus 17 yeah put a few hands I've
done about two or three versions myself
really nice to have it in the language
in fact
a big part of C plus plus 17 was taking
these commonly used types and making
them what we call vocabulary types
these are types that we use not just
very frequently but we also pass them
across API boundaries very often they
make our apis much nicer to work with
yeah I've written my own string view I
called it string ref but of course that
didn't interoperate very well with other
libraries that maybe had their own
version so really important to get these
sort of types in the language C plus
plus 17 really delivered there
let's look at another thing that he gave
us continuing with this example
What's um what's the big thing that's
missing here
why is this not a particularly a good
function so converting a string into an
integer
anyone
error handling yeah what happens if the
in the string doesn't actually have a
good representation of an integer
there's no way to communicate that now
we could of course throw an exception
we've had exceptions
for decades at this point but that's
actually not a very good fit for this
sort of thing you very often want to do
this sort of thing where well you know
what the string is
so you want to say well do you contain
an integer if so what is it don't do the
work twice and if not I want to take a
different path you want to do more
control flow
rather than I know this is an integer
it's an error if it's not
so you want to be a little bit a little
bit different
so in the old days
maybe we'll have been tempted to put the
result in a reference type reference
parameter what we might call an out
parameter
so we'll pass the the result out
into a reference that you pass in and
then the return value
it's free to be used for
you know your error signaling whether
it's a Boolean or something else
that works but it's a bit ugly a bit
error prone and of course you know you
can forget to check
that's very easy to do so
one other thing we've got in C plus plus
17 is no discard so if you do have
something that you really need to check
on your return type please please use no
discard
and as of C plus plus 20
I won't mention it there so I'll mention
it now you can you can provide a message
as well to to say why you shouldn't
discard it could be useful
so we actually got attributes in C plus
plus 11 I think
I didn't check that I think it was 11.
but we didn't have many back then I
think it was C plus plus 14 introduced
um deprecated we saw that on a slide no
discard but maybe the first particularly
useful one bigger you really should be
using this
but
it's still not a great API
you know reference return values is not
a good good way to do things
so of course we've got stood optional
this is a much better way to do it so
now we can say well either we converted
it to an integer in which case here it
is
all we didn't in which case it's an
empty optional
and actually the the usage is is really
straightforward
if we return the actual integer
automatically converts otherwise we can
return a null opt and to use it
there's a pointer semantics so we can we
can test it the same way that we can
test a pointer
so if it has a value
we haven't had to use a separate
initializer
and then we can dereference it like a
pointer
and if it doesn't have a value we can
just go into the else
you know we know all this but it's just
nice to see it coming in at this point
but
sometimes this is still not quite enough
maybe you you need to provide more
information about why you couldn't
produce that value
you know was it that it was just a
um a bad integer
was close to it or we don't know in some
cases it's more obvious than others but
there's no way with optional to put any
information
on the error side
now C plus plus 17
we did get stood variant which you could
use for this
so variant of course is a
closest we got to a real discriminated
Union
in C plus plus so something which is one
of several alternate types
and a way to distinguish what those
types are
uh sometimes called a
some type
so here we've got a variant of int or
stood area domain sorry domain error
um doesn't have to be domain error just
chose that
and now we've got a way to
provide a message along with the the
error to say why why it failed not
particularly useful in this case but
just for illustration
that works
in usage though it starts to get a bit
of a both
so to test which alternate type you have
you can use holds alternative
alternative
there's a couple of other things you can
do as well but that's sort of the
canonical way
um
to get the the value out used to get
with the type
again there's a way to do it by index as
well
you know it all works but
I do think that while it's good tested
variant in the language
it's actually useful concept
really this should be built into the
language we're not quite there yet
so for now but we're stuck with listed
variant for error handling though
it's um it's really not a good fit I
think
it's just um too too much boilerplate
I mean really
the amount of noise in that bottom
section it's something like you know 80
or a handling boilerplate I've I've done
other talks on this I go into a much
more depth you should see those for more
details but yeah it's uh we can do
better
yeah
but I've at least introduced stud
variant which has done a really valuable
if they're both
vocabulary type in C plus plus 17.
now you notice here see rather than with
uh if I go back
with optional we could declare our
optional return value and test it in a
single list statement because it has
those pointer semantics
well we went to stud variant work to do
those on separate lines
because we had to first get our result
and then test it accept that
another thing that came in the C plus
plus 17.
with the init statement
so now you can do the assignment and
then the test
all within the the if
statement itself
and the advantage to that
is that our result object there
is now scoped to within the Earth else
which means that you don't have to worry
about it leaking out to enclosing scopes
that's another nice little refinement
but we've got that in C plus plus 17.
so there's plenty more
that we've got in 17 that we haven't
really talked about
so we mentioned no discard optional
string view variant
um there's a lot more we could say about
variant including
if we do have like more types how do we
see which one each one is and what to do
with it we generally just stood visit
for that
who here has written their own visitor
pattern implementation
would have thought there'd be more just
a few hands though I call it the
unwelcome visitor because it's always
more code than you wanted but
we've at least got back in the standard
library for variant so it's a lot more
succinct than it would have been
otherwise
but it's still not really a very
ergonomic way to fiddle with variants
as I say there's stuff coming in the
pipe we're not quite there yet even with
23 but um we're going in the right
direction
we've got even more complex bro
I skipped over it in the C plus 14 slide
but
Concepts forgot relaxed quite a lot you
say plus plus 14.
um
I think we've got variables and loops
at least in certainly multiple return
statements
C plus plus 17 we've got even more again
I can't remember the details now I might
have overstated the C plus 14 but it's
evolving gradually to be more and more
relaxed more and more like normal code
but what we can do
is C plus plus 17. is particularly
memory allocation
and exceptions
and that rules out quite a lot of useful
code particularly things like
stud vectors and maps and other
containers at compile time
still couldn't quite do that in 17 but
we're getting there
context has been this constantly
evolving thing
talking to which ifcon's extra
is actually quite a big thing in 17 if
you're particularly if you're a library
writer or you're doing
template meta programming or any of that
sort of stuff
if contact can save you a ton of code
because it's basically just a diff that
can happen at compile time
and the evaluation only happens
depending on on the condition
not going to go into it in too much
depth but it's actually really powerful
for replacing loads of the template meta
programming code
um structured bindings was actually
quite a surprise entry into C plus plus
17 it came in at the 11th hour I think
pretty much after we thought
the design of C plus plus 17 was
complete it just got through the door
and it turned out to be quite a big
feature
if you don't use structured bindings
they're a way of
um sort of part of a pattern matching
syntax
uh the the structuring part or you can
think of it like
um python has multiple return values you
can destructure them into multiple
variables
gives us a way to do that in the
language you see plus plus 17. before we
may about to use someone like stood time
so all things that
just make the language more nicer and
more ergonomic to use
possibly accept stood variant which
makes it a bit more complex but we'll
brush that one another carpet
fold expressions
because I won't go into that too much
detail but if you're not familiar but
we've got variatic templates in C plus
11 but you had to do the template meta
Programming type things to work with
them public Expressions simplify a lot
of that
and once you get used to the syntax it's
a lot simpler
but it is a new syntax
so
again I'm not covering all of it here
turned out to be quite a quite a good
release slightly bigger than 14.
but not as big as
11 or as we'll say 20. and it missed
some of those big headline features
so
we come on to C plus plus 20.
yeah some of you got the references
remember we were promised con Concepts
ranges modules
co-routings contracts
what do we get
so this version of the slide
is from the first version I did of this
talk back in 2019 early 2019 to be more
specific
and I was saying yeah the design is
pretty much locked at this stage this is
what we're getting
who can spot the mistake
just shout it out
so contracts we're in and then they were
out and I was in the room when that
happened
so
yeah
contracts are a way of expressing
preconditions post conditions and
variants
originally developed in the context of
the language Eiffel
um but actually even C and hence C plus
plus has asserts which you can use as a
degenerate form of contracts you can
certainly Express preconditions and
things
um contracts would have been a way to
um be more nuanced about that more
controlled and more expressive
a lot of people really really really
want contracts including me but we have
to get it right
and it turned out again at the 11th Hour
just like the concepts before actually
we can't quite agree what we actually
mean
I know there's a bit of a problem so
yeah we took it out decided to regroup
formed a study group around it
and we'll try and get it in for 23.
um last I heard
it's not ready for 23. so
we're hoping 26.
I've heard it may not even make 26 but
in the meantime you can do it yourself
so hopefully it's not too bad but but
that was the controversial story of C
plus 20 but the good news is we've got
everything else
we've got ranges we've got Concepts
finally not quite C plus plus 11
Concepts oh sorry C plus plus Ox
Concepts
um I'll come back to that we've got Co
routines
and we've got modules
um most of these do come with some
asterisks though
so the only asterisk around Concepts I'd
say concepts has been a big success
and it's got some rough edges but
pretty much delivered but
C plus plus Ox had some extra features
this is what really caused the the
problems that eventually caused it to be
poured out perhaps the biggest of those
is what's called concept Maps who
remembers concept Maps
one or two people yeah not very well
known these days so maybe we're not
missing too much but actually I think
if we can eventually get them back in it
could be a big addition so Concepts
themselves allow us to uh limit or
constrain our apis uh in a way that's
also overloadable so it replaces loads
of really messy stuff we had before try
to make our apis ergonomic that's really
what it's about
um
concept maps go a step further and say
well okay
you don't quite match this constrained
API but I know how to adapt you so that
you can
and that really opens up a lot of ways
to interoperate bits of code that would
never been were never designed to
interoperate but but should
and I've seen this play out in other
languages really well but it has to be
done properly
and C plus plus just
makes things more complex
so we haven't got that yet maybe we will
one day
I don't know
but it's great that we've got Concepts
in the form that we have and in fact
right up until again the 11th Hour
it looked like we were going to have an
even more cut down version of Concepts
in particular
what we call the tour syntax
which allows us to say just um
Auto in a constrained type actually the
other way around
um
rather than having to spell out in a
concept and
be the more sort of template like syntax
didn't like didn't look like we were
going to get that in but we did so now
we have a much more succinct way to
specify not just Concepts
but just general templates again we've
got the auto keyword like we had in C
plus 14 with lambdas we now have that
for for function templates and class
templates as well
because it's part of the terse concept
syntax
so we go even further and constrain
those template types for example we can
say that this only
conforms to a particular iterator
category
and it would be a compiler error if it
doesn't and actually I think I've got an
example of that a bit later so I'll hold
off talking more about it
less Concepts
we've got so much more on here to talk
about
um but I said some of these had
asterisks so let's go through those
modules
we've got modules in C plus 20. it so
many of these came together right at the
last minute and we've got finally we've
got them in but
we've got the language feature
but modules really needs the ecosystem
and build system support to really work
so you can put modules in your code and
you won't be able to build it most of
the time if you're using visual studio
you might be able to I think they're
with their own version
cmake is starting to get some support
but
we really need some you know joined up
uh specifications here the trouble is
we really need is a specification for
how build systems should support modules
and unfortunately that's not what we say
is in the purview
of the C plus plus standard it's not
something that we can actually specify
in the standard document just by Design
just the iso rules really
so
we can't standardize that so the best
we've done is set up a study group
that will write a document suggesting
that this is how things should be done
and hope that builds all vendors will
pick that up
and that study group was filmed just
before the pandemic
and then they sort of fell very quiet
during the pandemic I think they're
picking up again now mostly been driven
by Bloomberg actually
so hopefully we'll get there but
I've been saying for years modules is
going to be a C plus plus 23 feature and
I'm now revising that
so maybe C plus plus 26
. we're not there yet which is
unfortunate because module was maybe
even more than all of the other features
here
has the power to completely transform
the way that we actually write C plus
plus maybe not line by line but the way
that we build C plus plus projects
um
We inherited the include the module
model from see it's basically just
copying and pasting text from one file
into another we know how that works we
know how error prone that can be and all
of the side effects of leaking
definitions and
build times and everything that these
two I once did a
a test where
I pre-compiled hello world I think it
was on windows at the time but it's
pretty much the same on any compiler it
may have done the same sort of thing
and the resulting file was
so many hundreds of thousands of lines
long
foreign
just because of that sexually include
inclusion model
no wonder our build times are so bad
modules has the ability or the promise
to cut through all of that
rather than textual inclusion it's just
linking against a pre-built interface
it's not going to go deeper than that at
this point
you probably know where
where that goes but
when we get it it's going to be a big
thing
so
yeah we've got modules where we haven't
got modules
let's start
co-routings
it's one of my favorite features from 20
actually I just did a talk on it just
recently
and as a language feature
it's not perfect but it's pretty good
now you may have seen co-routines in
other languages and it's a little bit
complex just in itself it's a complex
feature
in fact it's it's a way to express
complex problems
and they're almost most simple form
if that makes sense so you've taken a
complex thing and getting the simplest
version of it
then you do it in C plus plus
and you get all the complexities
actually this time it's not really about
references and stuff like that it's more
about that
um zero overhead principle don't pay for
what you don't use
you can actually write code readings
that literally have zero overhead
compared to writing the equivalent
yourself
which is quite impressive when you
consider what it's doing
um you can also write clothings that do
have some overhead you you will trade
that off but yeah we've achieved that
zero overhead principle at the cost of
a lot of code
that if who has actually tried color
routines in C plus plus
so a few hints uh who here thinks it's
simple
no no hands okay
right who's seen a talk on co-routines
but still doesn't understand them
more hands okay
yeah
um I think most people
they need to watch about two or three
talks before it starts to to sink in
uh certainly was the case for me uh and
I I went in knowing how color routines
worked I just needed to know how they
worked in C plus
and that takes three talks alone
that included My Own by the way
so they're complex they've made more
complex by C plus but the real killer is
they really need Library support
if you've tried to your C plus plus
contracts you'll know that there's a lot
of supporting code boilerplate code that
could be in the library
um in some cases more than others and we
don't have any Library support none at
all in C plus plus 20.
so no we were promised yep C plus plus
23 that's when that will be coming we'll
see we'll see but
in C plus plus 20 car routines are
usable if you're prepared to put in the
work
um but not for everyday
application developers I would say
which is a shame
spaceship on the other hand goes
completely the other way it takes
existing code and makes it simpler
it's probably the only language features
I know that that's that's the case for
so what is spaceship
also known as the the freeway comparison
operator
so rather than having to spell out
equals not equals less than greater than
less than equals greater than or equals
you could just write one spaceship
operator
has free return values about free yeah
values
you can return
and the compiler will synthesize the
rest
which is great to start with
you can actually go further and in many
cases
if all of your members already support
the freeway comparison it will
synthesize it for you without writing
any code
so it takes your existing code and makes
it better
so generally it's a big win there's a
few places where it interoperates badly
um
but I think overall
it's been a really nice feature
um
what do we risk ranges
so we talked about iterators how they're
such a game changer in C plus plus 98
but
those have a few problems
we already saw How spelling out the long
iterator types with TDS there's ways to
simplify that but
all the algorithms are specified in
terms of well usually two or three
iterators
still gets a bit tedious and they don't
compose very well
functionally compose if you need to
chain algorithms together
you generally have to
pass the iterators in get some out store
them then pass those store bonds into
another algorithm and so on
doesn't sound that bad but when you look
at what you can do in other languages
where you can just clean all these
operations together
now you see well we're missing something
so with their simplest
ranges are just a way to take two
iterators and put them together
so while this represents a range and
that's how they started out
just that alone
pretty much solves the composability
problem
because now you can pass in a range and
get out of range pass that range onto
another algorithm compose
but ranges goes further than that
gives you things like views and adapters
which actually let you do work without
the intermediate containers you might
have otherwise written
like earlier when we
did the conversion from integers to
Strings and we did an extra container
well if we wanted to do another
conversion after that we might even need
an extra container
what we can do all that work along the
way train them all together and miss out
all the intermediate steps
so in principle ranges are really good
in practice they're pretty good
but they've got some gaps
just like with some of the other
features there's bits to got put off
didn't quite make the cut we'll do that
later
which is fine oh
talking of getting cut off
they'll be the big overtime
[Music]
so I'm not going to repeat all those
jokes that I told while the audio was
off just assume that they were funny
that's um
I think that's
still recording so
doing a screen recording here so we need
to make sure that color is on
okay
where did we get to we're talking about
ranges I think we're pretty much done
we just said there's a few gaps
um I mean one good example is
just a little thing that was missing
that would have been really nice is the
zip
algorithm just takes two ranges
puts them together step by step
but there's a few things where
the specifications is you know you can
do this I don't have the example of the
top of my head but
it sort of works in maybe 80 of cases
and then 20 of the cases it will just
fall over with really hard to read error
message
which is unfortunate because one of the
things that Rangers was meant to do was
to give us good error messages
based heavily on Concepts
so it's a shame that we still have some
of those warts in it
they're gradually being addressed but
we're not quite there yet even in 23.
but it's um it's a big step forward
most of if not all of the algorithms
have ranged versions alongside the
existing iterator versions so you can
start using those straight away and just
get the benefits of that first level but
some of the more advanced stuff
it's a little bit
Rough Around the Edges for now
um
the other thing I'll just point out is
the concepts the story continues so in C
plus plus 20
we finally got the ability to do memory
allocations or new and delete at least
it's not actually memory allocation
and exceptions
at least you can write
try a catch
if an exception is actually thrown then
it's a compile error but
just supporting try catch actually gets
us most of the way there so we can now
have contacts from vector and map and
string
which is a huge step forward for cons
Express
pretty much the only thing you can't do
now is things that actually have side
effects
uh which which may be as far as we go so
yeah contact spray we also I haven't
really put it here but can't Steve now
the difference being contacts per can be
executed at compile time
whereas concert eval must be executed at
compile time and sometimes you need to
make that that choice
I think I've already covered the fact
that contract is out so oh honorable
mentioned two-step format which also
made it in it's the first step at least
towards replacing i o streams
so inspired by the way you do formatting
in Python
it's trying to make it easier safer and
more performant all at the same time
which is great in C plus plus 20 it only
really works for formatting strings
we're working on getting it to work for
input and output as well that's the next
step
a lot of work going on on student format
this example was for now oh yeah oh no
Okay so
this is actually to demonstrate Concepts
so imagine you have a function like this
what's a template function
called print that does takes a container
any container so we're taking it as a
template argument
so we can work with any container just
use a range base for Loop to iterate
over
let's put a bit of syntax around it so
yeah if you pass it a vector
and we call print on that
we'll get all the elements printed out
great I'm sure many of us have written
code much like this
trouble is
it's an open template
comparison is something that's not a
container
doesn't support range base 4.
and of course it won't compile but you
get the error sort of somewhere in the
middle of the implementation
you know where it tries to get iterators
out of the container
so yeah
an instantiation the function template
specialization
um
constant no viable begin function
available
it's hard to really decipher from that
what the problem is
so with Concepts
we can say okay T is a template argument
but it has to be something that conforms
to the input range concept
which itself supports the iterator model
so now the RMS you still get error
message
without saying you can't actually call
the function print
so it's at the call of the function you
get the error
and it says constraint not satisfied
what's the constraint expansion of
concept input range for T where T is an
INT
okay there's still a lot of words there
but it gets you to what the problem is
much more clearly
and that's a big part of what concepts
gives you
we could do things like this before but
there were really nasty workarounds uh
spinny stuff
um this is this is much nicer way to do
it
well this goes even further is you can
overload functions based on
a concept so you can have a different
function that works for different
Concepts
but we're not going to cover that for
now
let's have a look at this example again
remember when we talked about
Vector events converting them to Strings
using this to transform now the Lambda
so I mentioned ranges
makes it much simpler
just to compare that again so
we've got our
we're declaring our string vector and
then reserving it up front
and then calling Transformer passing it
two iterators
now
we can actually
declare the string
vector
transform it
and pipe it in all in one statement
with no intermediate steps
but this is much nicer
it takes a little bit of getting used to
it's like a new vocabulary to learn but
it's worth doing it
the code is so much simpler and better
still remember I said about
composability
putting an extra step in
you can just see it there in the in the
workflow
so they were just filtering out any
values that are uh
not divisible by two
just
that bit alone changes everything else
stays the same that's how it should be
that's not how it has been
so that's the power of ranges
okay we still have
one more language version to get to
I let the whole thing play
I like this bit and it gives me a chance
so we're going into the future now
I'm not that far off
when I first put these slides together
it's still four years away it's quite
scary really
ah never animation okay let's skip this
one right C plus plus 23. now we are now
at the stage
where it was the first time I gave this
talk to C plus plus 20.
the designer C plus plus 23 is pretty
much Frozen
so we should know what we've got in it
this is my slide from 2019.
these are the things we were expecting
to get into any free
right this is what we got
that's not 100 True
um the semester risk but yeah pretty
much none of those things got in some of
these were admittedly optimistic meta
classes I didn't really think that would
be in 23. even reflection was a bit
optimistic but I was hopeful
and pattern matching but yeah this was a
bit disappointing
obviously that's not the whole story
most of the things that have made in I
didn't even know about back then some of
them I did
let's have a look these are some of the
important things
there's a few there we'll get to those
but let's just write in what we didn't
get
uh so I slightly modified this I said no
co-routing libraries but actually it's
no creating task libraries so the last
minute update
I heard that uh co-routine generators
have made it in
they've still got to be had the wording
finalized but it's been prioritized
that stood generator for cover teams
will make it in so we'll be able to
write the simple forms of Kobe teams
with Library support in C plus plus 23 I
think that's a big step
so I'm glad about that
but note I think task libraries yet
still no contracts
uh no executors now we haven't really
talked about Executives I mentioned back
in the C plus 11. segment that we had
the start of
support for paranormal programming we've
got the memory model we've got some
basic primitive like mutex and things
like that but we needed some higher
level stuff
obviously we've got co-routines which
help with some async workflows
Executives Were Meant to to get us all
the way down a full async workflow
um
framework
and we were talking about those from
I remember hearing talks before c plus
14 about what Executives were going to
look like
and every year they changed
until maybe a year ago
or two I can't remember
we decided actually that wasn't really
going to work out
so we switched to a new model called
stood execution
um
based on this this idea called senders
receivers
it's the same sort of idea just a
different approach to it and uh there's
a Facebook I think library that
implements this idea
there's a huge
amount of interest in getting still
execution into C plus 23 was I think the
number one priority at least for the
library side
and it looked like up until the last
minute it was going to make it
but it didn't so yeah we don't have
Executives or state execution
Maybe 26.
but what did we get
okay
there's a few things here I'm going to
demonstrate some of them
um concept expert almost all the things
I should forget now
what else we've got on the context for
the front so I'm not going to talk about
that
maybe the headline feature which I don't
have an example for is deducing this
which I thought was going to be a small
feature but actually it's got a lot of
implications
do you think this is
a way of well let's let's take a step
back
we're going to all know that this
pointer
so we've had since the early days of C
plus plus should have been a reference
but it's a pointer
this might actually change that
but it's always been implicit
when you call a method you've got you
this pointer there
but it can actually have a different
value category
it's always a pointer but it might be a
const pointer
it may even be a an R value
um it all depends on what you put at the
end of the method signature it's a bit
const it's the const pointer and if you
put an already reference it's an eye bag
but that's the only control we had over
it
another problem we had
how often have you had to write
a constant a non-const version of the
same
method
I'll throw a couple of hands come up but
I actually ask how many times anyway
it's something we have to do and we
either duplicate the code
or we we call the
uh the non-conf version from the const
version
let's just constant unconscious and then
you throw in our valleys as well and
um there's a few other things that we
should put in but we never do
and I think I actually need about five
or six different versions to do it
properly
a lot of the standard Library types do
if I knew there was a way that we could
actually
make the this pointer into a template
argument
and that's what did you see in this
allows us to do we can finally specify
that this argument as an argument to the
function much like you do in Python okay
go back to python
and because because you can make a
template argument
you can also deduce the value category
and you can make it a reference
this opens up turns out a load of things
so the original motivation was just
through reducing that duplication
but it turns out you can do things like
um
or crtp who knows crtp
quite a few hints okay I know what sort
of crowd we've got now
curiously recurring template pattern
where you actually passed a um your own
type down to a beta class of the
template argument so it can call you
back
um it's called compile time polymorphism
well we're deducing this you don't
actually need to do all of that
because if you call a base class
from the perspective of the static
instance through the dynamic instance
it gets the dynamic type deduced
so you've already got it there you don't
need to pass it down as part of the type
which makes it so much simpler and
there's loads of other things recursive
lambdas
um
should read the paper because it's just
so many things that they discovered that
it's opened up so it's one of those um
one of those features that
you know it's right because all these
things that were being blocked suddenly
open up so it's really big feature it's
gonna again change the way we write a
lot of code
and it made in
then some smaller things like
multi-dimensional
subscript operator well that made it in
early and as a result we've got MD MD
span and mdra
for multi-dimensional arrays
um I think some of the others I'm gonna
talk about by example so let's move on
all right yeah we looked at this example
earlier
where we're trying to do our conversion
from string to integer but we want to do
error handling we tried optional we said
what if we want to supply a message
along with it
we tried variant
it works but it's a bit clunky
we can do better
in C plus plus 23
we can do stood expected which does the
same job
but you can see there's a lot less code
and actually if you look closely
the only real difference is between this
and optional are exactly the things that
matter
you specifying the error type
they can specify what happens in the
error case
and
when we're handling it in the arrow case
we can get the error out everything else
is just the same as stood optional
this is much nicer to work with it's
much more tailored to supporting error
handling
now if you've seen any of my error
handling talks you know we can go even
further still there's proposals for that
I'm not going to get into that now but
this is a great start
so I'm really happy about this
now if we go back to the optional
version
but this one I looked at earlier
um there's even more we can do here as
well so
in this case we've got one function that
returns an optional parsing let's throw
in a couple more
we've got divide
which um will give you acidic unexpected
sorry I still expected if
you you give it a division by zero
and one more function that doesn't have
optional tool
just to see what happens there
now with optional today
as of C plus plus 17 or 20 you would
write code that uses these functions
like this if you want to compose them
together
so we call powers in we store the result
okay we can use the initializer syntax
to reduce it a bit
then we test the result if we've got it
we dereference it and pass it on to
divide but capture the result test that
the reference that and pass it on to add
one
and then we've got all the error cases
I mean it's it's straightforward enough
but it's tedious code to follow
and the more you compose these functions
the Messier it gets
so C plus plus 23
we finally got the magnetic operations
posted optional
you don't have to know what magnetic
functions are to know that you can write
code like this it's the same same thing
again
today C plus plus 23.
again look at the the flow
we call parsing and then we call divide
and then we transform the result of that
third one
it just is the right order
so that's the sampling of what we're
going to be getting you see plus plus 23
unless of course we have one of those
things we have to pull everything out at
the last minute I don't think so with
these though
so we should be good this time
there's lots more I haven't covered but
that's actually
the material that I had prepared for
the main talk
I did say I had some bonus material uh
we got time to do a little bit more
but maybe five minutes
brilliant okay
so
I'm gonna
load something up
there we go now
so I said I did a talk recently on code
readings one of the reasons I'm
interested in Co routings
is well I don't know if you heard
um I wrote a test framework
a few years ago
called catch
since I heard about C plus co-ratings I
started wondering whether it would
actually be
a good idea to build a test framework on
top of co-routings
what do I mean by that well
this is what I had in mind so
this is just prototype code
in fact there you can see the whole code
base is 150 lines of code
including the entire implementation
including all of the co-routines
boilerplate we should add
so
right here's a test
now the one downside is you always have
to return something that is a
co-routine task object
local test
but apart from that this looks very much
like catch if you if you can use catch
um I'm not sure what I think this is a
problem with yeah ignored the red lines
it does work
so we've got these require macros
that allow you to do these comparisons
and if you've used catch you'll know
that
what we actually do we'll skip that for
a minute
and go to here
so what happens is it does require
it calls this operator
that captures the left hand side of the
expression
and returns an expression LHS
and with expression LHS
with an overload various operators have
we've got two here
to capture the right hand side and the
operator so now we're building up our
complete expression
we return that as a
expression with types
that just stores all of the information
we've got that's pretty much how catch
Works already obviously a cut down
version
what's new here
is
if I look in that require again
requires actually doing co-yield
so it's yielding out of our co-rooting
every time you you do an insertion
with this require type and our operator
now if we look at
this issues code
so this is really that the runner
for our test framework if you like so
we're creating the test object the Tesco
routine and then we just Loop through
we'll keep resuming until resume returns
false so that's gonna
keep generating new assertion values
in fact it returns an associate info
that's what captures all of that
information that we we saw at the end of
the expression decomposition we get that
out here
and we can say
file a line number because we've got
Source location
now in C plus plus 20
we've got a string version of the
expression
and the result whether it passed or
failed
that's it
now the nice thing about this is we were
able to get out of our test function
without exceptions
in cash if I
a test case fails early we have to throw
an exception to get out but now we have
another way out and that's one of the
reasons I was interested in this because
not everywhere
lets you use exceptions there's places
that can't use catch as a result
and this would be a really nice way to
to get around that so it's just a toy
thing at the moment
we'll see where it goes so there are
some limitations but I just wanted to
give you a taste of what you can do with
code readings
and if you're interested I won't dwell
on it too much but
we can actually have a look at the where
is it
some of the co-routine boilerplate here
we go
so test is our clothing task type
it has a promise type
where you have these are the
required functions I have to implement
we've got some custom States
and what happens every time you yield a
value
we'll set the store a cover Gene handle
and
is there API for it so what happens when
you do resume
getting the result
getting the assertion info
and that's actually all there is to it
once you
do get to grips with Co routines you can
actually boil it down to something
relatively straightforward
if you'd never think everything's before
this looks pretty alien but
it's not too bad
but that's that's it that's my bonus
material as well
so I'm gonna
just come back here
so I can finally say